A man had two daughters.
One was married to a farmer, and the other to a brick maker.
The man wanted to give one wish to each daughter.
He went to the daughter who had married the farmer,...
...and asked how she was and if there was anything she needed.
The daughter said, "Everything is fine father."
"I only have one wish. I wish that it will rain so that my husband's plants will grow."
The man then went to visit the daughter who had married the brick maker.
He also asked her how she was, and if there was anything she needed.
She replied, "I have everything I need...
..."except that I want many fine days so that the sun will dry the bricks my husband has made."
The father then told her,...
"I don't know what to wish for the two of you."
"Your sister wants rain, and you want dry, sunny weather."
"Whatever I wish for, it will not please one of you."